hello how you doing it's an iconic
disney princess in front of me
first of all what can you tell us about
this version
i mean it's it's brandy new it's so
sparkly it's really how i feel about it
cause i'm like oh god it's just
but it's i mean it's amazing we've got
brand new music brand new costumes brand
new characters which is so exciting for
me because i think the brand new
characters add so much to the movie and
uh and getting to interact with so many
incredible actors our crew was so
incredible i'm just the luckiest girl in
hollywood truly i am well i'm so excited
i wanted to know what is gal like as a
villain oh my god it's so funny you
wouldn't expect it because she plays
literally the the beacon of justice and
goodness in the dc universe um which is
so funny i mean she does an incredible
job it was one of those things where she
we had our first scene together and at
the end of that first scene she really
like lets me have it and she left the
room and i was like gal's mad it was
great it was so good i was like mommy's
angry
it was great she's wonderful awesome it
was great talking to you congratulations
[Music]
you